hello there today we're going to look at
on the measure of intelligence by
Francois Shola of Google this is a bit
of a special episode I would say because
if you look at the paper it is first of
all it's very long and then second of
all it is a wall of text basically now
it's very interesting text but if I were
to go through this with you we'd
basically just be kind of scrolling and
reading alone so what I've done is I've
basically read this and taken notes and
I will attempt to just tell you what
happens at least for the first part so
intent for this to be a multi-part
series because it's so long so the first
part as you can see here is context and
history which is a little less boring
than it sounds
the second part is going to be a new
perspective where Shola proposes his
measure of intelligence and the third
part is going to be about the benchmark
the arc benchmark that is currently I
believe running on Kago so as it sees as
it looks right now three parts and today
we're going to dive into that first part
so here we go he basically says that we
need to define what intelligence means
we need an explicit goal to measure what
if we if we think about AI like
artificial intelligence what does
intelligence mean we need something
where we can basically put a number or
multiple numbers on it says that's
intelligence that's not intelligent what
we have right now is just basically
anecdotes is just we all kind of feel
what seems intelligent but we are not
like sure and sometimes it's very
misleading he brings up the Turing test
for example which is that you have you
have a computer or a human behind a wall
and on the other end say it's a human
and the human needs to kind of
communicate without seeing what he
communal what he or she communicates
with and then determine whether or not
on the others
of the wall is a human or a computer and
if the computer could fool a human into
kind of a 50/50 guess then the computer
would be passing the Turing test and
therefore intelligent now surely doesn't
go right now into why that's not
sufficient but he's basically saying
this is not sufficient it's distracting
and second of all it's basically just
outsourcing the problems of defining
intelligence to human right to this
human right here well who is fallible
and noisy and you know doesn't all
doesn't really know all you all you tell
the human is basically like is this
thing intelligent does this thing seem
human to you it's also not clearly
defined so we need some something more
and shalay says the definitions that
exist today of intelligence are
basically they they have implicit they
are implicit definitions that are loaded
with biases and biases basically from a
human perspective on what intelligence
is and if we want to really make
progress in terms of measuring
intelligence we need to point out these
biases that are in these measures okay
they has a range of quotes namely one
here intelligence measures an agent's
ability to achieve goals in a wide range
of environments that was I believe the
conclusion of a author that distilled
lots of different definitions and try to
distill them into one one sentence and
that's it intelligence measures and the
agents ability to achieve goals in a
wide range of environments so the
crucial parts here is to ability to
achieve goals so it must the agent must
be you know doing something useful doing
like in reinforcement learning we say
must be getting higher rewards and the
second part is in a wide range of
environments so the the notion right
here that we're going to encounter time
and time again
is basically an addition of skill and
adaptivity so if you have it's not
enough to have high skill you also need
to be kind of adaptive to very very
different environments to a range of
environments and that's this this is the
main issue that Shirley has with the
current sort of definitions of
intelligence and the current direction
of the AI field because it mostly
measures skill and not generalization or
adaptivity now he he says in this thing
in this sentence right here that you
just saw there is an implicit sort of
something is said implicitly namely that
these these these skills this ability to
achieve goals in this wide range of
environments it must be acquired it must
be learned these these new tasks these
different environments the agent should
basically learn to adapt to the
different environments then and then the
agent is intelligent it's not that
intelligent when it is sort of
pre-programmed
to already handle these environments so
he says that's that sort of implicit in
that statement and we're gonna see how
this is made explicit later he goes into
basically there are two two different
viewpoints on intelligence this old
nature versus nurture debate and that
refers to two things like crystallized
intelligence versus skill acquisition
intelligence so the evolutionary view
would be that intelligence is sort of
this stead of static programs and here
we we simply kind of boil down these two
views to their extremes right so don't I
don't think any major evolutionary
biologist is complete like his apps is
that extreme right now um but these were
historical set of views that were held
one of them was that intelligence is
basically just it's it's all
pre-programmed into you by evolution so
you can you can solve this puzzle
because during evolution you know your
ancestors that could solve these puzzles
were were survived you can plan your
path through a a tree jungle because you
know that was beneficiary to you and so
evolution put that into your brain and
therefore what results is AI is the
science of making machines capable of
performing tasks that would require
intelligence if done by humans
that's basically what Minsky said the
quote I believe by Minsky at least
Sholay says it's by Minsky or I misread
where if you have this this set of view
that that AI is basically just this set
of static programs that means that if a
human applies that set of programs to a
task right and the human achieves 200
points it means if the if an AI comes
along and achieves 201 points then it is
intelligent because it has simply the
better set of the the better it has
outperformed this static set of programs
intelligence is this static set of
programs and the AI has a better set of
static set of programs so it's basically
Minsky says if we know of a task that
would require intelligence if done by a
human then if something that can solve
that task is intelligent and this
equates learning basically just to
memorization if you ask a proponent of
this viewpoint well what's what's
learning like if everything is
pre-programmed what we can still learn
and they would say yeah but the learning
is just you memorize situations and that
particular ability is also
pre-programmed into you the other
extreme view point is this tabula rasa
view point where it basically says you
come into this world and your brain is a
blank slate and everything you all of
your abilities you basically must
acquire through learning
throughout your life so this is another
extreme viewpoint and in terms of
intelligence where that leads is
following AI is the science and
engineering of making machines do tasks
they have never seen and have not been
prepared for beforehand and that's a
quote by McCarthy and Friedberg if we're
ever to make a machine that will speak
understand translate human languages
solve mathematical problems with
imagination practice a profession or
direct an organization either we must
reduce these activities to a science so
exact that we can tell a machine
precisely how to go about doing them or
we must develop a machine that can do
things without being told precisely how
so this leads to more of of these
notions right here that you can see here
half the machines have not been prepared
for a particular situation so if we make
a machine that can do a task that it has
not been prepared for we we know it's
basically intelligent and again so if we
make a machine that can do all of these
things all of the things right here then
either Friedberg says we must reduce
these activities to excite so basically
we must program the solution in there
already or we must develop a machine
that can do things without being told
precisely how and as as you might
realize this is much closer to the to
the machine learning paradigm it's
basically it's all about how much you
say precisely because the extreme
proponent of this thing would would
basically recognize any sort of learning
anything that you haven't seen before is
an intelligent right if you if you can
handle any new situation you're
intelligent and so there is going to
argue that that's also not really the
case like we have to be a bit more
graded about it but this is basically
the machine learning approach it's it's
we build machines that can do things
without being told precisely how that
they have not been prepared for
beforehand like it can solve things that
are not in the training data that's one
interpretation and if you're a very
strong proponent of this you would call
that intelligent and surely is gonna
argue that the truth of course is
somewhere in the middle between these
two viewpoints and therefore defining
intelligence in either of these terms is
going to lack in in expert Civet II and
in usefulness so how do we evaluate AI
and surely goes through different levels
here of AI evaluation so first of all he
contrasts these these two things right
here skill based evaluation and
generalization based evaluation so in
skill based evaluation you basically go
for one given task so you evaluate a
system on one given task one example
here is for example the Turing test and
that's done by human review another
example is where you have like a proof
so you evaluate a system in by giving
its optimality proof you can analyze it
and you can say it is always correct at
this particular task what you can also
do is this pure competition so this is
maybe what we see in sort of like chess
so we let the bots play first humans and
then we let them play other BOTS and we
determine which one's the best and also
the most familiar one benchmarks so this
would be where your I don't know your
image net net test set is right that's
right here that's a skill based
evaluation that's one given task how
well can you solve the image net test
set without looking at it
that's one task
so the problem Shirley says with these
skill based evaluation is sort of
obvious it's like a single focus you
can't like you are only good at this
particular thing and that is one of the
examples of this is the fact that the
Kaggle models are usually the winning
Kaggle models are usually useless
outside of that particular data set
because they're just so hyper optimized
and hyper focused on winning that
particular cattle competition so it's
actually it's actually a pretty strong
science on how to set up a cackle
competition such that you can then use
the model the winning model afterwards
for doing something actually useful no
there are no conditions on how to arrive
at a solution and they're surely let's a
bit of that that's basically his point
that's gonna come in to the the
measurement later into the math where he
says you simply have to arrive at a
solution in this scale based evaluation
this skill based evaluation usually
doesn't care how you arrive there so the
imagenet test set score doesn't care how
you got the neural network or what not
that you got it simply cares how many
images do you classify correctly and
this leads to what is called the AI
effect which I didn't know it was called
like this until recently but it's fairly
obvious where people say people say
people come up with a task that's that
is intelligent so people used to say Oh
checkers the game of checkers
it requires intelligence and then you
build a machine to solve checkers Big E
because you can just I don't know search
do like a bit of a smart tree search and
you solve it and you tell them here's
like a tree search that does checkers
and there's a yeah but that's not that's
not really intelligent it's just like a
tree search but but chess chess you
can't possibly do that to treat the full
tree search so chess is intelligent and
the then you build like a smarter tree
search rebuild it stock
and they're like yeah but that's just
you know that's just this machine thing
and so the goal posts keep moving every
time they come up with a task and you
solve the tasks they'll just say well
that's not really intelligence this next
task
that's intelligence and it's easy to see
that if you just do this skill based
evaluation you will never get there
because it's always going to be on the
next task the next task
the next task it's overly
anthropocentric it's overly based on how
humans view the world and what is not
left in here and again this this
acquisition what is not in this
definition is the fact that why do we
think that someone that plays chess very
well like what do we think Magnus
Carlsen is smart why do we think someone
like a go master is very intelligent and
that's because we know that this person
is human at least we believe there are
doubts about his some of these
grandmasters but we believe that they
are humans and therefore we know that
they have only had whatever twenty
thirty years to learn this and they must
eat regularly and they can only think so
fast and it's it's hard to memorize
things as a human so we know all of
their constraints that went into
learning this and we we basically know
there is it's not like we are not aware
of something like neo has in the matrix
where you can just upload the solution
to chess into your brain we know what's
required to achieve that level of
success and we know the only way it this
can be done is through general
intelligence we know that there is this
correlation in humans that if you are
good at chess you must have this or
you're very very likely to have this
general problem-solving ability right
that's a human centric view and that
does not count for machines machines can
take forever to calculate they can
distill years and years of
experience like thousands of years and
this would also this would be the same
case with this open AI Delta 5 right
dota 5 is exactly here alphago is
exactly here we only think they might be
intelligent if a human does it because
we know what's required for humans to
get there again focus skill acquisition
now you might be a board a little bit ok
it's about skill acquisition but think
about it it's it's not that easy to
actually define this skill acquisition
thing it without falling back into the
exact same trap so it goes on to say
okay as opposed to this skill based we
can measure generalization so what's the
generalization generalization is the
broad ability to handle tasks that
differ from previous tasks so they they
you have a task and it's different from
previous tasks you generalize now there
are two ways you can view this there is
system centric generalization and that's
basically if you take the strict
definition here so this would be a
machine learning system trains on the
training set and then it is evaluated on
the tests that it has never seen the
test set before so it's generalizing
right that's called system central
generalization but that's not really
enough here because we also need to take
into account the developer of the system
so developer aware or generalization
means that you generalize these
situations that are new to the system
and to the developer so a developer of
an image net model knows that it is
going to be evaluated on the image net
test set and that is that is in this
category system centric because the
developer knows however a broader
generalization this developer aware
generalization also takes into account
that fact and it would say developer
aware generalization is only when the
system generalized
to something that is not known to
developer that is new to even to the
developer themselves they don't they
haven't foreseen that so this accounts
for prior knowledge of the developer it
surely defines different degrees of
generalization largely along these lines
so absence of generalization is when you
have like an algorithm that you know you
absolutely have built in that it works
for every possible situation like like a
cert a sorting algorithm that you have
proven mathematically proven to work for
all sequences of numbers
no generalization everything has been
foreseen then there is local
generalization and this in machine
learning we call this something like
robustness this would be your test set
robustness your a small distribution
shift so the test set here comes from a
known distribution so this is the the
notion of known unknowns you you have an
idea of what can come at your system and
you require basically you require a
dense sampling of the input space
usually machine learning training sets
are very very densely sample that means
there's a lot of data there that we can
learn from so we have like lots and lots
and lots and lots and lots of data and
when the test point comes it is going to
be like somewhere really in within
between all of these training data
points so we can infer from the
surrounding training data points what
the test data point is going to be like
if there's a classification boundary
right here we can sort of
nearest-neighbor it and there are
arguments that deep networks are
basically large nearest neighbor
classifiers but that's a topic for
another day and we are here basically we
are here in machine learning right now
we do local generalization we know our
unknowns we know our test set as yep the
opposition to this is broad
generalization broad generalization is
where you don't know what you don't know
unknown unknowns you don't know what
comes at
time and you can't rebuild sort of your
expectations into the system this is
more akin to something like level five
autonomous driving where you build this
car but you don't really know what kind
of situations coming no known this is a
this is a fuzzy definition right I mean
you do sort of know what situations will
come at the car you can certainly
probabilistically make a statement about
what so this is it's not a clear-cut
definition and I think we're going to so
in the math it seems clear cut but when
we get there I don't think it is that
clear-cut
honestly it's still kind of a intuition
thing what you categorize is local and
broad and so on also here the wazniak
coffee cup example where it basically
wasn't accessed you should be able to
build a robot that goes into any kitchen
and gets you a cup of coffee and here
you have known sorry unknown unknowns
because you can't possibly foresee all
possible kitchen arrangements there
might be obstacles and so on do you know
that coffee might there might be
different coffee makers that you've
never encountered before but I've been
saying that this is a bit of a trick
right here because what what you can
always do is you can construct a room a
kitchen right and right here is the
coffee machine so there's the how do we
draw this there's the coffee machine
right here one of these fancy Nespresso
machines you put in a capsule here and
here's the coffee machine okay but then
you build a wall around it and the wall
has a door and the door the door will
only open if the if you solve an IQ test
right so or any sort of any service or
whatever you put whatever you put in
that spot that's the level of
generalization you you can achieve
basically so you can always up the level
of generalization to
or you can put I don't know you can put
the halting problem here right you can
you can you can here you can say you
only solve this door if you can would
ever give me a proof of the ABC
conjecture something like this so coffee
cup example kind of kind of has some
back doors in any case you sort of know
what was the AK means you should be able
to go into a standard kitchen but the
standard kitchens are still diverse
enough you can't foresee all of them
like I I don't if any of you has this
sort of kitchen that I'm talking about
like mad respect all we will all get
this robot and you'll you'll just have
to wait for the next iteration okay
then there's extreme extreme
generalization is where you have kind of
open-ended you you don't know what's
gonna come you don't even know the broad
category of tasks that is going to come
right broad here is still broad still
refers to a broad category of related
tasks so it is sort of a general ability
and the extreme generalization just
means you know whatever whatever comes
you can solve it but it is different
from universal the universal
generalization chalet says is any
conceivable task in the universe and
that's pointless it's pointless because
it's just too much there's this no free
lunch theorem right plus what we
actually want is we want human level
intelligence and human level
intelligence has this property of
extreme generalization with extreme
generalization we mean the scope see
it's dependent on a scope we mean the
scope of all human tasks of all tasks
that humans could producer could find
useful could find themselves in or could
pose of this system not all tasks that
the universe could pose so that here you
you don't even
the relation between tasks the relation
between tasks are at most abstract so
there may be it's like the general
ability of sorting things generally in
in whatever fashion in and things
whatever these things are with whatever
properties or the general ability to
communicate an idea or something like
this and this in humans is called the
g-factor
if you or it's related to but we're
going to take like shrill a really goes
after psychometrics here and really
models its his framework after
psychometrics for humans and the sort of
achievement in psychometrics one of the
achievements is this measure of the G
factor and that's what we humans usually
call intelligence
he says note that humans have system
centric and developer aware
generalization though you know that one
this this and count this contains the
other one so why because we can handle
situations that previous humans haven't
experienced now I'm not I'm not sure it
basically says humans have developer
aware generalization because we can we
can fare well in situations that no
humans during evolution have experienced
prior but ok let's let's have this
abstractly let's say our developer is
the evolution process you still have to
ask can humans really solve things that
M the evolutionary process has not built
into them in some sort I guess that
refers back to the nature versus nurture
like humans humans cannot you know
multiply long floating point numbers it
doesn't matter how I get without a pen
and paper it doesn't matter how how much
you learn or something like this there
are some things that they just can't do
but
would want to do and I guess the
evolutionary path simply didn't provide
us for doing that kind of stuff we have
a finite working memory and so on so I
think the discussion here is still to be
had if we really do have developer of
aware generalization if you consider our
developer to be the evolutionary process
but but we can forgive a little bit here
so this is the general diagram that also
emerges from kind of theories of
intelligence from psychology where
generally you have a general
intelligence factor which is one factor
this is quite remarkable in humans there
is one general intelligence factor
statistically all that all these general
intelligence tasks they broadly
correlate and lead to one statistical
factor it's not a it's not obvious why
that should be but turns out to be one
factor and that distributes
hierarchically into these things which
are called broad abilities brought
cognitive abilities and in Sheila's
framework that would correspond to broad
generalization and then these are again
hierarchically subdivided and sometimes
as you can see here shared tasks
specific skills okay and this in
initialize framework would be local or
no generalization so again he basically
to psychometrics and specifically IQ
tests for humans can they inform the
measuring process the note then the
thing to note here according to shalay
is in an IQ test you want to measure
these broad abilities you want to
measure ultimately you want to measure G
but if even if you measure different
things in psychometrics you want to
measure these broad abilities but these
are like these are abstract concepts so
what you're left with what you can only
do is you can only measure really tasks
okay and it's this
wrongly numbered or is this intentional
I don't know you can only measure tasks
but you somehow have to make an
inference about the broad ability from
measuring the tasks so that's the
difficulty in psychometrics I do you
want to measure the abilities but you
can only measure tasks the abilities are
abstract concepts and the still are the
measurable things where you can put a
number on it now you you can so what is
IQ tests do they usually usually employ
these broad battery of tests so you
don't give the human just one tasks you
give you give the human a lot of tasks
you've like okay complete this series
which number comes next draw like rotate
this in your head and so on but there
there are so very human centric things
like reading comprehension and so on but
you do this broad battery of tests and
you might think oh oh okay this is sort
of like the Atari you know sweet where
the one reinforcement learning agent has
to solve this whole bunch of Atari games
or a superglue in NLP where one NLP
system has to learn to do all these
different NLP tests you know there is
entailments there is sentiment there is
boolean question answering and but this
is according to shalay it's sort of not
really it's not really the case that
these are equivalent because it is a
battery but it is known to the developer
so the developer knows that the NLP
system has to solve the superglue things
so the developer can first of all train
the system until it reaches a good
superglue score but then also it will
have built in already the assumptions of
the developer that you have to solve
this so the second important thing about
these battery of tests and IQ tests is
that they are unknown to the test it
they tested cannot or ideally should not
practice for them that's why people keep
developing new and new IQ tests
because we sort of know they all
correlate first of all so they measure
the same thing but also second because
otherwise people if you just always do
the same test people could practice it
and then you would no longer measure the
general ability you would only measure
that one test by the way that's also why
a lot of these you know brain brain
exercise apps and so on they none of
them really ups your intelligence you
you you only get better at one app if
you do that you don't you don't get
smarter in general so if and and Shola
says there have been a number of
attempts at making machines making AI
solve human IQ tests right well the
reasoning is the follows like oh okay
humans develop IQ tests for humans and
presumably those are not known and so on
but again the tasks broadly of IQ tests
are known I guess really IQ tests work
on humans because they only work on
humans who don't really care like if
someone really really really really
cared they would you know research what
kind of tests there are they would look
at all the tests from history there's
only so many tests you can come up with
the new ones are gonna be like
variations on the old ones so you could
technically if you really wanted you
could like prepare super hard and that's
exactly what developers are going to do
they're basically going to look at all
these tasks they're going to pre solve
the problem and then they're going to
program their you know pre solved
solution into an AI system so we can't
just let AI systems of human IQ tests
what we need are tests that are reliable
which means they're reproducible
that are valid that means they really
measure IQ or they really measure
artificial intelligence and not you know
just tasks specific skill or something
else they're standardized across the
bactrim so they're standardized so
everyone can do them in the same way by
the way the current benchmarks are
standardized that's the good part about
them and they should be this should be
free from bias which means they should
not measure anything orthogonal to what
they claim to measure and the example he
gives is they should not measure
reaction time which is also a big
component in human IQ tests you also
measure how fast the human is at the
test and the Machine obviously if we
simply put more electrons through the
cable it's going to run faster you can
or if you put more more GPUs there so in
broad terms we what we should focus on
is this new skill acquisition as I said
from the beginning but it is not as easy
as you might think right now and we're
going to dive into the next episode and
is going to be math heavy and that's
going to be fun so I hope you enjoyed
this kind of special episode maybe let
me know if you like this style it the
paper doesn't have any pictures so
you're just left with what I'm what I'm
drawing yeah if you enjoyed this leave
like we've comment share it out and I'll
see you next time bye bye